every election there's a slight concern
of foreign bribery
influencing the outcome of the election
whether that be trump in russia
or biden in ukraine but at the end of
the day
it's usually proven that the allegations
are false or
that there is no substantial evidence at
the very least
however the upcoming 2020 election is
almost entirely based on bribery
and it's not some sort of illegal
collusion with the foreign giant
but rather a legal internal bribery of
citizens
using stimulus
given the ongoing global pandemic it's
no doubt that people need help
though either side disagrees on the
system that would best serve the
citizens
who actually need it it is agreed that
money should reach those in need
in one way or another however the issue
arises when the stimulus or tax cut
money or whatever the source
becomes a key point in a presidential
campaign and
unfortunately that's exactly what's
taking place
right now with both campaigns now of
course
there is an element of financial bribing
of citizens in every election
whether that be in the form of tax cuts
or more welfare
but this time it's different as the
financial incentives are not only
exponentially larger
but also direct for instance let's take
a look at trump's recent executive
orders
his first order extends unemployment
benefits at a lower rate of 400
per week of course there are concerns
about how he will actually fund these
checks every week
but assuming he's able to pull it off
though these checks
are for a noble cause there is an aspect
of driving
after all this does directly give 400
a week to over 30 million people as for
trump's extended student relief program
well it's pretty clear that trump isn't
the most popular within younger crowds
and what better way to gain popularity
amongst this crowd than cut student loan
interest
and payments which often cripples young
adults
moving on to trump's eviction bin this
is the least
bribe-like order as the financial
incentives are the most indirect
moreover they don't actually eliminate
or reduce rent or mortgage
they simply push them off for another
day plus
this doesn't affect everyone but just
people whose eviction or foreclosure
may accelerate the spread and finally
that brings me onto trump's payroll tax
cut currently
it's not a tax cut but simply a tax
deferral
however trump has stated that if he is
re-elected
he will attempt to get it forgiven and
possibly even terminated altogether
if he is re-elected and is able to
terminate the payroll attacks
indefinitely
it would prove to be a good amount of
savings for the average american
the median household income in the us is
sixty one thousand nine hundred thirty
seven dollars
calling it sixty grand a seven point six
five percent payroll tax cut would give
the average household
a four thousand five hundred ninety
dollar tax cut for american households
making one hundred thousand dollars a
year or more
which is over thirty percent of
households this savings would be a
minimum of seventy six hundred dollars
per year
so definitely quite a significant amount
but
if this really is as important as he
says why wait till after election to do
this
why not do it after congress gets back
from rhesus
which is a whole other issue in itself
but that's definitely something to
consider
now i'm not just picking on president
trump here
this is the same case with the other
side as well if not more so
joe biden is looking to spend 700
billion dollars to help the economy
recover
his plan includes spending 400 billion
over four years
buying up various us-based goods and
services
which would hopefully reinvigorate
hiring and reduce
unemployment aside from this he also
wants to spend 300 billion dollars on
technological research and development
as for his stimulus focused economic
plans his official campaign page
literally states that there will be no
limit to spending
stating quote biden believes we must
spend whatever it takes
though that does sound super patriotic
handing out a bunch of money
isn't necessarily the most effective nor
smartest move
biden's stimulus plan will cover 100 of
an individual's weekly salary
up to fourteen hundred dollars per week
which is the same as fifty six hundred
dollars a month or 72
800 a year so if you're married and
we're making good money before
you can make up to 145 000 600 per year
just from these weekly checks now of
course
this plan is more of a temporary fix and
only meant to last a couple of weeks
or a couple of months for the hybrid
recipient but
let's not forget about his running mate
miss harris
wants to give out two thousand dollars
per month to individuals earning under
one hundred thousand dollars per year
this stimulus also extends up to three
dependents as well
so a family of five could claim ten
thousand dollars per month
as long as your household income is less
than two hundred thousand dollars
and these checks are usually based on
one suggested gross income
so families making 230 to 240 000
per year could likely also qualify for
their full check
after deductions and charitable givings
and such thus
a family of five would receive up to 120
per year which could boost their
household income up to 360 000
per year i'm not really sure the average
family of five really needs anywhere
near this amount
unless of course you're living in
california or new york
but for the average american this would
be quite overkill
and this isn't just for a couple of
weeks or months
but for the remainder of the pandemic so
on the presidential level
trump is offering stimulus in the tens
of thousands of dollars
while biden is offering in the several
tens of thousands of dollars
and even hundreds of thousands of
dollars most voters will probably just
vote along party lines
however for independents who don't
really mind either candidate
they may be swayed by the financial
incentives though there is a fundamental
issue with voters being influenced by
financial incentives or
basically bribery it's not really the
voter's fault
as it's just common sense to vote for
the candidate who offers greater
benefits to you
individually really the only concern
would be the national debt
which is definitely something to keep in
mind but
let's be honest here the average voter
will place much greater emphasis
on the stimulus as opposed to the
national debt
and that's just reality however where
this issue becomes an even bigger deal
is with congress as their powers allow
for them to offer even greater financial
incentives
trump and biden only have power over
hundreds of billions of dollars
if that as they usually need
congressional approval to pass most
things relating to money
congress on the other hand has power
over trillions
and their debates and disagreements are
likewise in the trillions
on a congressional level we've already
passed the cares act which cost over two
trillion dollars
on top of this even republicans are
willing to pass another trillion in
stimulus
while democrats are looking for another
3 trillion clearly
both sides are ready to give stimulus in
the trillions
and i'm sure that this is coming from a
good place for the most part
but a side benefit nonetheless is
garnering greater support from your
constituents
by giving them more financial incentives
right now
i don't think either side has very much
unwavering support
as they went on recess without passing
anything
but i think you guys get the point at
the end of the day
the pandemic has led to a rise in
citizens financially depending on the
government
and both sides on both the congressional
as well as the presidential level
have thrown out money not just as aid
but as a move to further their own
political agendas
i'm not saying this money isn't
justified but simply that come november
the appeal of the financial incentives
offered by either side
may very well determine national state
and congressional elections
and whether it's justified or not and
whether it's right or wrong
the circumstances have led to an
unprecedented election
that will largely be influenced by how
much the candidates have previously
given
out and how much they will give out
moving forward
in other words we have ourselves the
bribe wars
of 2020. do you guys think this is
acceptable given the circumstances
comment that down below also if you guys
like this analysis
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions largely answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one